Im Zweiten Weltkrieg war auch die
Existenz des Zirkus Knie bedroht.
Herr Gesandter.
- Herr Stadtpräsident.
Nach einer Vorstellung empfing
Margrit den deutschen Gesandten.
Dem Programm fehlt schon etwas
der internationale Glanz.
Wegen Ihren Behörden dürfen
wir aus dem Deutschen Reich
keine Artisten
mehr verpflichten.
Ein Auftritt vor dem Führer
würde sicherlich helfen.
Excusez, ich will ja
nicht unhöflich sein,
aber wird Berlin nicht immer wieder
von den Alliierten bombardiert?
Es herrscht Krieg.
Margrit musste sich entscheiden.
Ein Auftritt ihrer
beiden Söhne in Berlin
hätte die Zukunft des
Zirkus retten können.
Aber er hätte auch das Ende
der Dynastie bedeuten können.
Sie entschied sich für den
Auftritt und damit für den Zirkus,
der dieses Jahr Jubiläum feiert.
(Fredy Knie jun.) Mein Vater hat
mir sicher vieles nicht gesagt.
Das eine oder andere habe ich
von der Grossmutter erfahren.
Aber ich weiss - das hat er mir
erzählt -, dass sie in Berlin waren,
mein Onkel im einen Variété,
er mit den Tieren im anderen.
Im Wintergarten trat sein
Vater Fredy senior auf,
mit seinen Pferden.
Und in der Scala sein Onkel Rolf
senior, mit seinen Elefanten.
Das Nazi-Regime hatte sehr
grosses Interesse daran,
dass die bekannten Brüder
Knie in Berlin auftreten.
Das war eine Zeit, als die
Nazi-Grössen im Publikum sassen.
Man war ziemlich gut informiert,
was im Krieg vor sich ging.
Ja, wir mussten überleben.
Ja, es war schwierig.
Ich würde sagen, das ist
ein dunkles Kapitel.
Und es ist auch eines, über das
Knies nicht so sprechen wollten.
Weil das wahrscheinlich
vom Schweizer Publikum
sehr schlecht
goutiert worden wäre.
Einen Hochseilakt machten
auch ihre Tiere:
Rolf senior führte einen
Elefanten über das Seil.
Das funktionierte nur,
weil intensives Training grosses
Vertrauen geschaffen hatte.
Am Anfang, als wir diese Nummer
mit dem Elefanten geübt hatten,
hatte er Angst. Er hielt mich mit
dem Rüssel immer an der Hand.
Manchmal hat er sogar gezittert.
Aber meine Hand liess er
nicht los, denn er wusste,
wenn ich in der Nähe bin, ist er
sicher und fällt nicht hinunter.
Aber dann, als die
beiden Brüder auftraten,
haben die Alliierten Berlin
aus der Luft angegriffen.
* Bedrohliche Klänge *
Bomben fielen, Sirene heulten
und Explosionen
erschütterten die Stadt.
Als wir in Deutschland waren
und bombardiert wurden,
hatten die Elefanten Angst.
Wir blieben nahe bei ihnen.
Sie haben uns da auch mit dem
Rüssel an der Hand gepackt.
Wie um zu sagen: "Wenn ihr hier
seid, haben wir weniger Angst."
Mit uns haben sie
sich sicher gefühlt.
Aber sicher war natürlich niemand,
und den beiden Brüdern war klar:
Sie müssen mit ihrem ganzen Tross
so schnell wie möglich weg.
Fredy senior und mein Vater mussten
dann mit den Tieren flüchten,
weil die Bomben fielen usw.
Man wusste natürlich nicht, dass
Berlin gerade bombardiert wird,
während sie dort auftreten.
Zu Hause in Rapperswil
hielt es ihre Mutter Margrit vor
lauter Sorge fast nicht aus.
Immer noch keine Nachricht
aus Berlin von ihren Söhnen.
* Düstere Klänge *
Darf ich Ihnen einen Tee machen?
- Nein.
Einen Cognac viel... - Nein!
Danke.
* Das Telefon klingelt. *
Da ist Knie. Wer ist am Apparat?
* Rauschen, Knacken *
* Donnern *
Falsch verbunden.
Zu dieser Uhrzeit?
Ich bin sicher, Ihre
Söhne sind wohlauf.
Ich hoffe es.
* Das Telefon klingelt. *
Sonnenhof, wer spricht?
- Hallo, hier ist Fredy.
Fredy! Aus Berlin!
Fredy? - Mama?
Hallo? Hörst du mich? Ich bin's.
Es ging alles gut.
Bei Rolf auch.
Wo bist du?
Am Bahnhof. Wir können
gleich losfahren.
* Lautes Knallen *
Was ist das für ein Lärm?
- Nichts, nichts. Ich muss gehen.
Ja. Geh, Fredy!
* Unheilvolle Klänge *
Ich werde für sie beten.
Sie hörten dann auf, bevor
der Vertrag fertig war.
Sie gingen.
Sie entkamen gerade noch.
Mein Vater war hart,
kein Weichei.
Er sagte ungern:
"Ich hatte Angst."
Aber er hat mir schon erzählt,
dass sie schnell gehen mussten,
schnell einladen in den Bahnwaggon,
abfahren in die Schweiz.
* Geheimnisvolle,
anschwellende Klänge *
Auf der Tournee durch die Schweiz ist
der Zirkus Knie im Moment in Luzern.
Auch immer dabei sind die zwei guten
Seelen, die Knies mit den Kostümen,
aber auch im Haushalt und mit
den Kindern unterstützen.
Alma ist für mich definitiv
nicht nur eine Nanny,
nicht nur eine Mitarbeiterin,
auf keinen Fall.
Sie ist Teil meiner Familie.
Seit ich mich erinnern kann,
ist sie hier bei uns.
Ich kann es mir hier ohne
sie schwer vorstellen.
Als Ivan ein Jahr
alt war, kam ich.
Dann schaute ich auf Chanel.
Und jetzt auf den Kleinen hier.
* Maycol quengelt. *
Ja!
I want banana with Nutella.
Uuh!
I want the glass to dip.
What do you ... - Like this.
No! You can take it like this.
Put everywhere!
Maira, how many years are you here?
Twelve oder 14.
What's that?
- How many years do you work here?
I started 2008 again.
Yeah, and before? - 1995-1998.
Das macht, 1995 ...- Like 13,
14 years, something like this.
14 Jahre - sie machte einfach einen
Unterbruch, ging nach Hause,
drei Kinder machen.
Dann kam sie wieder.
Maira ist bei mir,
Alma bei Géraldine.
Beide sind Bramantes
der Neuzeit.
Sie sind auch sehr treu
und Familienmitglieder.
Die Haushälterin von Margrit
nannte man immer nur Bramante.
Eine tüchtige Italienerin,
die Margrit über 35
Jahre lang begleitete.
Ja, sie war wie ein
Butler für Grossmutter.
Sie machte alles für sie.
Zwischen Grossmutter und
Bramante war eine Art Hassliebe.
Sie konnten einander
so nehmen, aber ...
Ich glaube, sie hätten
es nicht gekonnt,
wenn sie nicht zusammen
gewesen wären.
Lange kann die Familie jeweils
nicht gemütlich beisammensitzen.
Denn die Leute wollen jeden Abend
eine perfekte Vorstellung sehen.
Schliesslich zahlen
sie dafür Eintritt.
Das sind drei Billetts für heute um 20 Uhr.
- Vielen Dank!
Programmmagazine!
Avanti, prego! Qui è
l'entrata 1 e 2, 3 e 4.
* Stimmengewirr *
* Fröhliche,
energiegeladene Musik *
Kaum sitzen alle Zuschauer
auf ihren Plätzen,
gehen die Platzanweiser
anderen Aufgaben nach.
Im Hintergrund sorgen sie
als Requisiteure dafür,
dass auch in der Manege alles
am richtigen Platz landet.
* Klagende Streichmusik
und Schlagzeug *
Viele dieser Mitarbeiter
kommen beim Zirkus Knie
seit Jahrzehnten aus Marokko.
Marokkaner sind kraftvoll.
Sie haben keine solchen
Rückenschäden wie die Europäer.
Wenn sie schwer tragen
müssen, laufen sie.
Und man muss sie nicht
antreiben, sondern zurückhalten.
Das ist natürlich ein
grosser Vorteil.
Und es sind liebe Mitarbeiter, sie
sind sehr anständig und dankbar.
Einige Marokkaner sind seit
über 20 Jahre bei uns.
Familie Knie ist
heute noch stolz
auf ihre langjährige Verbundenheit
mit ihren Mitarbeitern aus Marokko.
Nicht ganz so stolz ist sie auf die
Anfänge dieser Zusammenarbeit.
Das ist eine verrückte
Geschichte:
Früher stellte man ja
nicht nur Tiere aus,
man stellte auch Völker aus.
Völkerschauen nannte man das.
Da kamen Marokkaner:
Schlangenbeschwörer, solche,
die mit Leder arbeiteten,
Holzschnitzer.
Heute kann man sich das
nicht mehr vorstellen.
Aber zu Beginn des letzten
Jahrhunderts war das gross in Mode.
Völkerschauen gab es
schon sehr lange -
in ganz Europa.
Man stellte wirklich Menschen
aus aus fremden Kulturen.
Dort sah man Dinge, denen man sonst
natürlich nicht jeden Tag begegnete.
Wenn die Leute etwas über
Marokko wissen wollten,
konnten sie das bei uns sehen,
live mit diesen Leuten.
Jetzt wird es auf den
ethischen Aspekt ...
"Man stellte Leute aus."
Aber das ist kein
Ausstellen, das ist ...
... Kultur rüberbringen.
(Originalkommentar) Die
Swissair hat aus USA Gäste
für den Schweizer Nationalcircus
nach Zürich gebracht.
Den grossen Häuptling Eisernes
Pferd und seine Familie,
zu der die Kinder Kleine weisse
Taube und Geflecktes Pony gehören.
Diese Leute waren dann hier
unter doch recht anderen
klimatischen Bedingungen.
Sie bekamen Krankheiten,
gegen die sie keine
Abwehrstoffe hatten,
weil sie das nicht
gewohnt waren.
Die ganzen Völkerschauen sind
ein ganz schlimmes Kapitel
in unserer Geschichte.
Sie sind nichts, worauf
man stolz sein kann.
Damals war man aber
fasziniert vom Andersartigen.
Von Kleinwüchsigen z.B.,
die im Zirkus in einem
kleinen Dorf lebten.
Die haben auch in der
Vorstellung gearbeitet,
die haben einen ganzen
Teil der Vorstellung ...
Es gab Jongleure, Akrobatik,
sie machten Velonummern.
Aber es waren alles kleine
Leute mit kleinen Velos.
Das war damals ...
Man sah es im Zirkus,
bewunderte es und fand es gut.
Ich war etwa gleich gross,
habe mit ihnen gespielt,
obwohl sie erwachsene Menschen
waren und ich ein Kind war.
Diese Völkerschauen liefen
eine Zeit lang sehr gut.
Aber plötzlich verloren die
Leute das Interesse daran.
Es fand dann natürlich
ein Wandel statt.
Einerseits fand man es unethisch,
andererseits war es so,
dass man die Länder
selbst bereisen konnte.
Knie beschloss in
den 60er-Jahren:
"Jetzt ist fertig mit
den Völkerschauen."
Zwei junge Marokkaner redeten
mit meinem Onkel und sagten:
"Wir möchten gern hierbleiben
und bei den Pferden arbeiten."
Mein Onkel sagte:
"Probieren wir es!"
Und so fing es an.
Es kamen dann immer mehr von
der Familien der beiden.
Sie kommen alle aus dem gleichen Dorf.
Verwandte und dann immer mehr.
Ja, es sollen alle
zu mir kommen.
Sind sie hier? - 16 Marokkaner
sind hier, Gott sei Dank.
Salut. - Salut.
* Alle reden durcheinander. *
(Fredy Knie jun.) Wir behandelten
sie genau gleich wie Italiener,
Österreicher oder Franzosen,
die bei uns arbeiteten.
Mein Vater und meine Vorfahren
machten da nie einen Unterschied.
Alle werden gleich behandelt:
Leute aus verschiedenen
Ländern, die mitarbeiten,
genauso wie
unterschiedliche Zuschauer.
Das ist das Fundament
des Zirkus Knie.
Wir positionieren uns ja nicht
politisch oder religiös.
Wir sind eigentlich ...
... richtige Schweizer,
wir sind neutral.
Wenn der Zirkus alle
ansprechen soll,
und zwar auch alle
Bevölkerungsschichten,
alle Leute mit diverser
politischer Couleur,
geht es darum, selbst keine
Stellung zu beziehen.
Zumindest im Selbstverständnis
von Familie Knie.
So wurden Knies erzogen -
auch Fredy junior, von
seiner Grossmutter.
Arrivederci, Signora Knie!
Buona giornata!
Arrivederci, altrettanto!
Nonna, wieso has...
- Nicht mit vollem Mund.
Wieso hast du dieser Frau
gesagt, wie du heisst?
Damit die Leute wissen, dass
Familie Knie bei ihnen einkauft.
Dann kommen sie mit ihren
Familien auch in den Zirkus.
Prima! Dann schenkt mir die Frau
sicher wieder etwas Lyoner.
Nein, nächstes Mal kaufen wir
woanders ein.- Was? Wieso?
War es nicht recht?
- Doch, schon.
Aber wir wollen alle Leute im Zirkus
und gehen darum bei allen einkaufen.
Heute waren wir bei Reformierten,
nächstes Mal sind es Katholiken.
Nonna? - Ja, Fredy?
Haben die Reformierten
auch Lyoner?
Ich glaube schon.
Das ist so eine alte Taktik,
und das machte sie wirklich.
Rapperswil war ganz
streng halb, halb.
Halb katholisch, halb reformiert.
Auch die Schulen waren getrennt.
Diese Trennerei war
eigentlich furchtbar.
Es gab Leute, die nur
in die katholischen
oder nur in die
protestantischen Läden gingen.
Und sie ging
demonstrativ in alle.
(Franco Knie jun.) Wir
sind das beste Beispiel,
dass Multikulti funktioniert.
Wir haben teilweise 14-15
verschiedene Nationen pro Saison.
Bei uns gibt es einfach die Regel:
Man spricht nicht über Politik,
nicht über Religion und man
beklaut sich gegenseitig nicht.
(Fredy Knie jun.) Man
muss tolerant sein,
sonst kann man nicht
so eng zusammenleben.
Wir sind auf engstem
Raum zusammen.
Es ist nicht wie
in einer Fabrik,
wo nach Feierabend jeder in
eine andere Richtung geht
und man sich erst am nächsten
Morgen in der Fabrik wiedersieht.
Wir sehen uns auch in
der Freizeit ständig.
* Anschwellende Streichmusik *
Zirkus ist die andere
Welt, weisst du.
Wir haben viele Kulturen:
Polen, Schweizer, Italiener,
Portugiesen, Russen, Chinesen.
Alles. Das gefällt mir gut.
Und wir haben einen
speziellen Dialekt für uns.
Arabisch, Polnisch,
Schweizerdeutsch ...
Ein Ort so, ein Ort
so, und wir machen.
Einer kommt von Polen:
"Nix verstehen",
versteht es aber schnell.
Eine schwierige Aufgabe
hat die Küche:
Sie muss bei ihren Menüs
die verschiedensten Essgewohnheiten
berücksichtigen - seit eh und je.
(Originalkommentar) In
Knies fahrender Küche
werden dreimal täglich für hungrige
Mägen Mahlzeiten zubereitet.
Kommt dazu, dass im Zirkus
ein internationaler Hunger
befriedigt werden will.
So essen die Marokkaner
kein Schweinefleisch,
die Nordländer wollen
keine Teigwaren
und die Südländer
keine Pommes frites.
Wer beim Zirkus Knie in
der Küche arbeiten will,
muss deshalb ganz besondere
Bedingungen erfüllen.
(Fredy Knie jun.) Wir hatten
jahrelang einen Schweizer Koch,
der sich wirklich Mühe gab: null
Schweinefleisch, null Alkohol.
Aber weil er nicht
ihrer Religion war,
waren sie immer misstrauisch.
Dann sagten wir: "Gebt uns die
Adresse eines marokkanischen Kochs!"
"Wir engagieren den, und
der kocht dann für uns."
Dann brachten sie einen mit.
Er bringt sogar seine
Kräuter aus Marokko mit.
Seither gibt es null Diskussionen
mehr wegen des Essens.
* Lautes Stimmengewirr *
Genau wie die
Requisiteure aus Marokko
kamen die Musiker
traditionell aus Polen.
Heute ist das Zirkusorchester
aber eine Mischung
aus verschiedenen
Nationalitäten.
Um hier zu arbeiten, muss man sich
besonders gut konzentrieren können.
Man muss die Show immer
im Auge behalten.
Deshalb brauche ich ein Headset.
Alle hören zu, was ich sage,
welche Nummer dran ist.
Eins, zwei, drei, vier, und es muss
sofort losgehen und richtig sein.
* Fröhliche, triumphale Musik *
Viele Leute meinen, die Pferde
machten die Schritte nach der Musik.
Nein, das ist der ...
Ein guter Zirkusdirigent muss in die
Manege schauen und so dirigieren.
Er muss nicht das Orchester
anschauen, sondern nach unten.
* Feine, fröhliche
Streichmusik *
* Entfernte Musik *
Franco junior und seine Familie sind
erst im zweiten Teil der Show dran.
Hi! - Hallo.
Komm, zieh dich um!
Über Generationen arbeiteten
sie mit Elefanten.
Aber das ist jetzt vorbei.
Ich habe es bis heute nicht
akzeptiert, aber ...
Ich denke, ich war genug ...
genug ...
... intelligent,
um zu verstehen,
dass es so ist und nicht
geändert werden kann.
* Entfernte Musik *
Ich bin der Meister
des Nägelfeilens.
Weil ich dazumal acht Elefanten
die Nägel schleifen musste -
mit der Flex.
Und mit Hufmessern und
allem Drum und Dran.
Und mit der Raspel.
Voilà.
Die neuen Partner haben
weder Hufe noch Nägel:
die Drohnen,
die Franco junior und seine Familie
in der Manege umhersurren lassen.
* Langsame Rockmusik *
Chris muss noch etwas herausfinden,
was seine Rolle sein wird,
denn er hat ja die
Elefanten nicht mehr.
Aber er hat es irgendwie im Blut.
Das finde ich schon mal gut.
Der Nachwuchs ist etwas
sehr Wichtiges im Zirkus.
Das ist übrigens auch ganz
typisch für Familienbetriebe:
an die Zukunft zu denken,
davon auszugehen, dass es immer
im Familienverbund weitergeht.
* Verklingende Musik, Applaus *
* Sanfte Klaviermusik *
Dass die jüngste Generation im Zirkus
einen wichtigen Stellenwert hat,
musste schon Margrit Knies
Sohn, Fredy senior, erleben.
Nein! Du hast
Schokolade gekauft?
Hast du mir auch eine?
- Weisst du, was das kostet?
Was willst du?
Schau, Herbert Leupin hat die ersten
Entwürfe für das Plakat geschickt.
Hm, zeig mal!
Aha.
* Wiehern *
Ein Clown, der
Buchstaben jongliert?
Das heisst Knie.
- Das sehe ich auch noch.
Müsste das nicht eher
ein Jongleur sein?
Nein, eben nicht, weil der Zirkus
Knie ...- Mach, was du willst!
* Wiehern *
Bravo!
Bravo, Kinder! Bravo!
Hier! Hopp!
Hopp!
Hopp! - Sie bekommen Schokolade?
Ja, das ist die Zukunft
unseres Zirkus.
Ich bin auch die Zukunft.
- So, jetzt.
* Friedliche Klaviermusik *
Meine Grossmutter
hatte uns alle gern.
Ich kann mich erinnern:
Als wir auftraten, war sie
dabei und schaute zu.
Dann war sie stolz, dass die nächste
Generation schon langsam kommt.
Im Zirkus gross zu werden und
inmitten von Tieren zu sein,
ist natürlich für
ein Kind spannend.
Es hat seine Vorteile, aber
es hat auch seine Nachteile.
Man lebt etwas in
einer eigenen Welt.
Und das finde ich immer
etwas gefährlich.
Aber gleichzeitig gibt es
Herzblut für den Zirkus.
Und das finde ich wunderschön.
In dieser Welt gibt es auch eine
Schule für die Zirkuskinder.
Als ich ein Kind war, hatten
wir keine Schule im Zirkus.
Zuerst war es schwierig für
uns, von den Eltern wegzugehen.
Es war für uns ...
Darum hatten wir eigentlich
auch so Horror vor der Schule.
Mir stank die Schule gewaltig.
Es war furchtbar, weg
vom Zirkus zu sein.
Das war unser Leben,
der geliebte Zirkus.
Weg von den Eltern zu
sein, war sehr hart.
Das war der Grund, dass wir,
als wir Kinder hatten, sagten:
"Fertig, Schluss!"
"Unsere Kinder kommen während der
Schulzeit nicht weg von uns."
"Wir haben eine Zirkusschule." Dann
eröffneten wir die Zirkusschule.
* Jubelrufe, liebliche
Klaviermusik*
(Ivan Knie) Viele denken, bei
einer Kindheit im Zirkus
werden die Kinder nur trainiert
oder machen nur Zirkus,
und das gehe nicht für ein Kind.
Das ist aber überhaupt
nicht der Fall.
Klar, je nach dem gibt es
schon Trainingszeiten.
Und die Schule muss
man halt machen.
Aber unsere Freizeit war
eine ganz normale Freizeit
mit Spielsachen,
Spielplatz - ganz normal.
16, 17, 18, 19, 20!
Chanel ist definitiv
ein bisschen schlauer
als ich in ihrem Alter war.
"Un po' più furba" sagen
wir auf Italienisch.
Sie hat auch komplett
andere Interessen.
Meine Schwester denkt nicht
einmal ans Playstation-Spielen.
Sie ist wirklich gut, spielt
den ganzen Tag draussen.
... zwei, eins! Ich ziehe auch.
Whoa!
(Fredy Knie jun.) Chanel
kann hinten spielen,
und alle meinen: "Du
kommst zu spät."
Nein, sie hört die Musik ganz
genau und sie kommt nie zu spät.
Sie kommt auf den letzten
Drücker, aber sie ist immer da.
Ivan z.B. hat mit zwölf angefangen
- vorher war es ein Kinderspiel,
aber mit zwölf oder 13 wusste
er: Die Leute haben gezahlt,
sie kommen und wollen etwas sehen
und nicht enttäuscht werden.
Er fing an zu überlegen, was
unser Beruf wirklich ist.
* Entfernte Musik,
rhythmisches Klatschen *
* Das Orchester spielt
"Happy Birthday". *
Heute wird Ivan 17.
Ein guter Grund,
gross zu feiern.
* Stimmengewirr *
An meinem Geburtstag wurden
alle Artisten eingeladen,
Freunde von mir, auch von ausserhalb
des Zirkus, habe ich eingeladen.
Die Worte, die sie gesagt
haben, berührten mich,
denn es sind schöne Worte,
und es ist schön zu wissen,
was jemand über einen denkt.
Ja, es ist einfach schön.
* Festmusik, Stimmengewirr *
Auch Ivans Grossvater,
Fredy junior,
feierte seinen 17.
Geburtstag im Zirkus.
Auch damals schon bis in
die frühen Morgenstunden.
* Rock-'n'-Roll-Musik, Jubel *
* Wiehern *
Papi?
Was machst du mit meinem
Geburtstagsgeschenk?
Gehst du ausreiten? - Nein.
Ich bringe es in den Stall, es
muss ja heute wieder arbeiten -
wie wir alle übrigens auch.
- Ach komm! Man wird nur einmal 17.
Der Zuschauer, der heute
Abend sein Billett zahlt,
interessiert sich herzlich
wenig für deinen Geburtstag.
Fredy, muss das sein?- Es ist 3
Uhr, und mein Sohn ist besoffen.
Ein Glas hatte er.
Und ich habe ihn dazu überredet.
Dein Sohn ist jetzt 17.
Ja, darum probt er jetzt den Aufstand.
Soll er doch!
Um 7 Uhr stehst du geputzt und
gestriegelt bei mir im Stall.
Natürlich.
Vielleicht nicht gerade um 7 Uhr.
- 7.00 Uhr. Und keine Minute später.
Komm! Wer feiern kann,
kann auch arbeiten.
Du bist zu streng mit ihm.
Das sagt die Richtige. Was
hast du immer gesagt?
"Ein Knie muss doppelt so hart
arbeiten wie alle anderen."
Was für unsere Generation galt,
gilt auch für die nächste.
3 Uhr ...
Halbstarke!
* Die Musik verklingt. *
7 Uhr morgens, am Tag
nach Ivans Geburtstag.
Und tatsächlich: Auch er steht
schon wieder in der Manege.
Ich glaube, wenn man
nachts Party machen kann,
kann man morgens auch proben.
Man muss sich ein bisschen in
den Arsch treten und sagen:
"Hör mal: Ich habe
gestern Party gemacht,
aber jetzt muss ich trotzdem
für die Tiere da sein."
V.a. für dieses Tier
hier, für Laureus.
Das Geschenk, das er
von seinem Grossvater
zum Geburtstag bekommen hat.
Als ich Laureus bekommen habe, war
ich sehr froh, überglücklich.
Es hat mich daran erinnert,
dass auch mein Grossvater sein Pferd
in meinem Alter bekommen hat.
(Fredy Knie jun.) Als ich ein
Jahr aus der Schule war,
habe ich ihn vom Vater bekommen.
Er konnte noch nichts.
Vater korrigierte
mich natürlich immer.
Aber eigentlich liess er mich auch
sehr viel allein machen mit ihm.
(Ivan) Er ist ja
mein erstes Pferd,
das ich ziemlich von
null auf trainiere.
Von null auf bedeutet, man muss ihm
sehr langsam, mit viel Geduld,
mit vielen Zeichen, mit viel
Stimme alles beibringen.
No! No! No! Rein!
Er hat die anderen draussen
gehört und wollte zu ihnen gehen.
Aber wir hatten es gut im Griff.
Es ist alles Gewöhnungssache.
Er ist neu da und muss sich
noch an vieles gewöhnen.
Hier, Laureus, hier, hier.
Brav, also!
Das ist brav.
Was ist das obendrauf?
Etwas wie Paniermehl.
Er macht jeden Tag Fortschritte.
Manchmal, wenn er eine Party
hatte, wie nach dem Geburtstag,
ist er etwas müde.
Aber sonst ist es gut.
Etwas mehr Luft lassen.
Luft, Luft!
Lass ihn mehr gehen! Ja.
* Zarte Streichklänge *
Mitten in den Zirkusalltag
platzt eine traurige Nachricht.
Die Zirkusfamilie erfährt, dass
Clown Spidi gestorben ist.
Ein Zirkus Knie ohne Spidi -
das ist ein harter Schlag.
* Schwere Streichklänge *
(Franco Knie sen.) Er war voll
integriert in der Zirkusfamilie.
Er sagte mir immer:
"Hier bin ich jemand."
"Hier spüre ich auch meine
Behinderung nicht."
"Ich bin genauso wichtig
wie die anderen auch."
"Ich bin ein Markenzeichen,
stehe vorne am Eingang,
begrüsse die Kinder
und das Publikum."
(Fredy Knie jun.) Durch
seine Kleinwüchsigkeit
hatte er sicher Probleme, die er
nicht nach aussen tragen wollte.
Ich sagte ihm stets: "Spidi, wenn
etwas ist, kommst du zu mir."
"Wir können über alles reden."
Man sieht halt am Schluss doch
nicht in die Leute hinein.
(Franco Knie jun.) Ich
verstehe es noch nicht.
Ich war an jenem
Nachmittag in der Manege,
kalibrierte die Drohnen
vor dem Auftritt.
Ich sah ihn vor dem Zirkuszelt, er
machte sich bereit für die Show.
Ich ziehe mich um,
ziehe den Frack an,
bin bereit, um die
Vorstellung zu eröffnen.
Dann sehe ich die Family mit Tränen
in den Augen. "Er hat sich erhängt."
"Was, wer hat sich
erhängt?" - "Spidi."
"Scheisse, was mache ich jetzt?
Ich muss in die Manege."
"Soll ich in sein Abteil rennen,
schauen gehen, ob man
noch etwas retten kann?"
Scheisse, dann stehst du vor 2'000
Zuschauern, solltest lachen,
einigermassen gut deinen
Text rüberbringen, aber ...
Ich glaube, an dem Tag habe
ich es nicht gut gemacht.
Äh ...
Es war ein Riesenschock.
Man verstand die Welt nicht mehr
und stand einfach sehr hilflos da.
Man hätte noch so gern ...
Und es standen so viele
offene Fragen im Raum.
Und natürlich unendlich traurig.
Es war ganz schlimm.
* Anschwellende
melancholische Klänge *
Gut zwei Wochen später trifft
sich die Zirkusfamilie im Zelt
zur Abdankungsfeier.
Extra aus Monaco angereist
ist Prinzessin Stéphanie.
Die ganze Schweiz kennt Spidi.
Wenn man in den Zirkus geht,
sieht man als Erstes Spidi
auf seinem Podest mit den
Programmen und den Ballons.
Es ist noch so neu.
Die Trauer ist gross.
Auch dass er am 100-Jahr-Jubiläum
nicht dabei sein wird.
Ich glaube, dass es zu Beginn der
nächsten Saison schwierig wird.
Für mich wird es jedenfalls komisch
sein, dass er nicht mehr da ist.
Spidi war immer für mich da.
Er hat nach den
Geburten meiner Kinder
für jedes gleich einen
Glücksbringer gekauft.
Er war wirklich eine
so herzliche Person.
26 Jahre, in denen man sich kennt,
gehen nicht einfach an einem vorbei.
Mit ihm war es wirklich
eine innige Beziehung.
Dadurch war der
Schock extrem gross.
Ja, das ist das Schlimmste -
nicht nur in dieser Saison.
Das ist das Schlimmste ...
... das allgemein
passieren konnte.
Wenn du bei Nacht den
Himmel anschaust,
wird es dir sein, als
lachten alle Sterne.
Weil ich auf einem von ihnen wohne,
weil ich auf einem von ihnen lache.
Jedes Mal, wenn wir die Sterne
unter dem Chapiteau anschauen,
werden wir an dich denken.
Mach's gut, Spidi!
Mach's gut, mein Freund!
* Applaus *
* Schwere Streichklänge *
(Ivan Knie) Als Spidi gestorben
ist, habe ich mich zurückgezogen,
habe geweint. Ich musste mich
zurückziehen, definitiv.
Am ersten Tag glaubte ich es nicht.
Für mich war er nicht gestorben.
Ich meine: Ich bin 17-jährig,
und Spidi war 25 Jahre hier.
Seit ich hier bin, ist er da.
Ich sehe ihn jeden
Tag, die ganze Zeit.
Und langsam fängt man
an zu verstehen.
Warte 1 Sek.! Die Person ist
wirklich nicht mehr da.
Und dann ...
Dann war es hart.
Aber Knies sind damit aufgewachsen,
dass es immer weitergehen muss.
Die Jubiläumstournee steht an,
und Mary-José trifft ihren
Schneider aus Paris,
um die Kostüme zu besprechen.
Ich brauche einen Frack, wie
meinen goldenen Frack damals.
Jetzt einfach schwarz. Weisst du,
wie damals mit den Seelöwen.
Ja, ja.
Ich habe eine Idee, wie
er nicht nur schwarz ist.
Schau, wenn man z.B. so etwas macht.
Das sind Perlen.
Aber ich möchte Pailletten.
- Pailletten, klar.
Siehst du? Damit könntest
du in Paris ausgehen.
Ah, sehr schön! - Wunderschön.
Wir arbeiten schon seit
14 Jahren zusammen.
Wir kennen uns gut.
Es ist wichtig zu wissen,
was jemandem steht,
wenn man Kostüme macht.
Mary-José hat sehr genaue
Vorstellungen davon, was sie möchte.
Manchmal sehe ich
etwas in einem Heft.
Dann schauen wir
das gemeinsam an.
Mary-José und ich machen
es wirklich gemeinsam.
Es entsteht miteinander.
- Bis zum Schluss.
Bis zum Schluss. Bis das
Ergebnis perfekt ist.
* Sanfte Klaviermusik *
Die Kostüme waren im Zirkus schon
zu Margrits Zeiten wichtig.
Eine Frau, die Mary-José
sehr beeindruckt hat.
Fredys Grossmutter war
eine spezielle Frau.
Wir haben Stunden
zusammen verbracht.
Sie hatte Klasse.
Als mir Fredy seine Grossmutter
vorstellte, war ich sehr nervös.
Und sehr beeindruckt.
* Langsame jazzige Musik *
Nonna, darf ich dir meine
Freundin vorstellen?
Fräulein Galland, Madame Knie.
Es freut mich sehr,
sie kennenzulernen.
Ich habe schon viel von Ihnen gehört.
- Grüezi.
Mary-José kommt heute
in die Vorstellung.
Ist sie nicht wunderschön?
Woher kommt sie?
- Aus Neuchâtel.
Nein, ich meine ihre Wurzeln.
Italien? Spanien? - Schweiz!
Dummes Zeug, die hat doch
etwas Südländisches.
Das sieht man doch.
- Sie ist Schweizerin wie wir.
Sie soll mir ihren Pass zeigen.
* Jazzige Musik *
Attends-moi dehors, chérie!
Ich komme gleich.
Es ist nicht wegen mir,
es ist wegen der Leute.
Das mit dem Händchenhalten
könnt ihr gleich lassen.
Wenn dein Vater das sieht,
bekommst du etwas zu hören.
Weisst du wie viele junge ledige
Frauen täglich in den Zirkus kommen,
weil sie ihren Traumprinzen
auf dem Pferd sehen wollen?
Die wollen wir
nicht enttäuschen.
Wir verkaufen Träume, Fredy,
auch was unser
Privatleben angeht.
Nur was im Wohnwagen passiert,
ist wirklich privat.
Meine Grossmutter war sehr
kontrolliert, sehr diszipliniert.
Sie war sehr darauf bedacht,
einen guten Eindruck zu machen,
gegen aussen natürlich sowieso.
* Verspielte Klaviermusik *
Viens avec moi, je te
montre quelque chose.
Mais qu'est-ce qu'il y a?
- Papa.
Was willst du mir zeigen?
- Es ist eine surprise.
Fräulein Galland?
Kommen Sie her!
Äh, wann? - Jetzt.
Weiss Fredy eigentlich,
dass unsere Ungaren Ihnen
heimlich das Reiten beibringen?
Was? Nein. Woher wissen Sie das?
Glauben Sie nicht, dass
hier etwas geheim bleibt!
Ich wollte nur ...
- Schon recht, wenn Sie etwas ausprobieren.
Schauen Sie einfach, dass
Fredy es von Ihnen erfährt
und nicht auf dem Latrinenweg!
- Latrinen?
Hintenrum. Von jemand anderem.
Bei uns wird draussen
keine Wäschen aufgehängt.
Schon gar nicht am Sonntag. Der
ist unserem Publikum heilig.
Am Sonntag verboten. Das
machten nur die Neuen.
Und sie hängten kein zweites Mal am
Sonntag die Wäsche nach draussen.
Es wurde immer pingelig geschaut,
dass alles picobello sauber ist,
wenn sie ein Gelände
wieder verlassen haben.
Dort waren sie vielleicht manchmal
fast etwas überspitzt bürgerlich,
um ja nicht in Verdacht zu geraten,
ein luderiges Leben zu führen.
Auch heute schauen wir noch darauf
- vielleicht etwas weniger streng,
aber es soll schon
ordentlich aussehen.
Heute Abend sind Sie
mit mir an der Kasse.
Andere Unternehmen machen teure
Untersuchungen, um herauszufinden,
was die Kunden wollen.
Wir machen das hier.
Es gibt keinen besseren Ort, um
zu erfahren, wo der Schuh drückt.
Und ausserdem: Wenn die
Leute in den Zirkus gehen,
wollen sie die Familie sehen
- auch beim Bezahlen.
* Zarte magische Klänge *
Und während alle anderen
in der Vorstellung sind,
rechnen wir zwei die
Tagesseinnahmen aus. Im Kopf.
Und wenn das Zelt voll ist,
gibt es nachher einen Cognac.
Rauchen Sie? - Oui.
Diesen Ring müssen
Sie noch ausziehen.
Aber ... das ist ein
Geschenk von Fredy.
Dann erst recht. In der Familie
Knie zeigt man nicht, was man hat.
In der Kasse mache
ich es jeweils so.
Dann habe ich die Hände frei,
um das Geld zu zählen.
Tu m'as manqué.
Was sollen die Leute denken?
- Du lernst aber schnell.
Wollten Sie Fredy nicht
noch etwas zeigen?
Deine Nummer auf dem Pferd?
Ich habe dir letztes
Mal zugeschaut.
Et ...
T'en penses quoi?
Steif wie ein Besen.
Aber: Wir können daran arbeiten.
Wenn du willst.
Es ist einfach so:
Wenn wir das tun,
dann machen wir es richtig.
Die angeheirateten Frauen
waren immer an der Kasse.
Bis ich gekommen bin.
Ich machte auch Zirkusnummern.
Aber sie sagten mir: "Das
kann eine Frau nicht."
"Das schaffst du nie." Aber
ich habe es geschafft.
Ich wusste: Wenn ich in der
Manege auftreten will,
muss ich mehr oder weniger
auf ihrem Niveau sein.
* Rhythmische Marschmusik *
Zum Glück hatte ich zwei
fantastische Lehrer:
meinen Schwiegervater und Fredy.
Wenn sie etwas im Kopf
hatte, zog sie es durch.
Sie hat sehr fleissig
trainiert und auch zugehört.
Mein Vater hatte etwas mehr
Geduld mit ihr als ich.
Aber das ist ja fast normal.
Aber wir haben es hinbekommen.
Wären sie nicht
zufrieden gewesen,
hätten sie mich nicht mehr
in die Manege gelassen.
Nach einer Saison hätten sie gesagt:
"Es ist besser, wenn du aufhörst."
"Bleib im Wohnwagen, geh an die
Kasse oder mach etwas anderes!"
Ich hätte sagen müssen:
"Du, geh an den Kochherd!"
Aber das wollte sie nicht.
Mary-José fühlte sich
immer wohl in der Manege
und hat als ehemaliges
Model schon früh begonnen,
sich auch um die
Kostüme zu kümmern.
Ich nehme mir viel Zeit für die Kostüme.
Es ist extrem wichtig.
Etwas Kitsch im Zirkus darf schon
sein, aber einfach nicht zu viel.
Es muss auch eine gewisse
Eleganz und Klasse haben.
* Zarte, verspielte
Klaviermusik *
Die meisten Kostüme für
die Jubiläumstournee
werden in Paris geschneidert.
Damit diese dann so aussehen, wie
es sich Mary-José vorstellte,
geht sie persönlich ins
Atelier Mine Barral Vergez.
Nur zu, du kennst dich ja aus.
Fühl dich wie zu Hause!
Hallo zusammen. Wie geht es Ihnen?
- Hallo!
Ich bringe Schweizer Schokolade
- wie immer. - Vielen Dank.
Kommt alles gut?
Wie immer. - Wie immer.
* Stimmengewirr *
Bon, à notre première!
- A notre première! Santé.
Der Mantel von Chanel
ist doch so, rot?
Der Mantel schon. Aber
das Gilet ist schwarz.
Der Mantel ist rot.
Und was hat es auf dem roten Mantel?
Husarenverschlüsse?
Auf dem Bild, das wir
als Basis haben,
ist eine kleine schwarze Weste
mit Husarenverschlüssen.
Dann hat es noch
einen roten Mantel.
Un petit manteau en velours.
Kurzfristige, rein technische
Änderungen in letzter Minute
sind sehr ärgerlich. Das kann die
Stickerei völlig kaputt machen.
Denn die Zeichnungen
der Stickereien
sind ja auf den Millimeter
genau abgestimmt.
Wenn also etwas
geändert werden muss,
ist das schon eine
kleine Katastrophe.
Ça va? - Et toi, ma petite?
Ça va.
- Tu es arrivée hier soir?
Je suis arrivée hier
soir, de Londre.
Auch Pauline kommt vorbei, die
Tochter von Prinzessin Stéphanie.
Sie liebt den Zirkus
genau wie ihre Mutter
und möchte deshalb unbedingt die
ersten Kostümentwürfe sehen.
Das waren die schönsten
Momente meiner Kindheit.
Ich habe unglaubliche
Erinnerungen:
Es war völlig normal, dass
ich nach dem Aufstehen
bei meinen Elefanten
im Zirkus war.
Es war eine sehr unbeschwerte,
sehr, sehr schöne Kindheit.
Pauline war im Jahr 2001
selbst mit dabei auf Tournee -
weil ihre Mutter Stéphanie mit
Franco senior liiert war.
Wir hatten uns schon
lange gekannt,
und in dem Moment kamen
wir einfach zusammen.
Es ist keine besonders
aufregende Geschichte,
es ist einfach so passiert.
So ist das Leben.
Zum Glück war es so, wir hatten
eine sehr schöne Zeit zusammen.
Wir konnten es nicht
verheimlichen.
Schon als wir in Monte Carlo
waren, gab es Paparazzi und ...
Es ging sehr schnell. Ja, ja.
Es waren alle etwas erstaunt.
Und alle wollten mehr erfahren
und wissen, was läuft.
Das war schon belastend.
Und mühsam.
Diese Beziehung stand dann bei
den Journalisten, in den Medien,
überall im Vordergrund.
Das wollte ich eigentlich nicht.
Ich wollte eigentlich den Zirkus
in den Vordergrund stellen.
Und sie natürlich auch. Sie
liebt Zirkus über alles.
Aber eben - es hat mit ihrer Person
zu tun, man fand das spannend.
Der Zirkus ist wie
ein kleines Dorf,
das vom einen Ort in
den nächsten zieht.
Es war extrem
bereichernd, so zu leben.
Ein wunderbarer Lebensstil.
Sie ist ja vom Charakter her ...
Sie wollte nie eine
Prinzessin sein oder so.
Sie ist sehr bodenständig und ...
Ja.
Das ist ...
Tempi passati.
Prinzessin Stéphanie
erinnert sich gerne daran,
wie ihre kleine Pauline
auf einem Elefanten ritt.
Es war wirklich etwas
Besonderes und sehr schön -
die echte Kameradschaft
zwischen dem riesigen Elefanten
und einem kleinen Mädchen.
Es war richtige Liebe.
* Heitere Orchestermusik *
Ich glaube, das war für meine
Kinder und mich die schönste Zeit.
Der Elefant nahm mich,
als wäre ich ein Baby.
Das war unglaublich.
Er hat für immer einen
Platz in meinem Herzen.
Aber jetzt geht es
um die Kostüme.
Zum ersten Mal probiert Mary-José
den Frack aus Pailletten an.
Wir müssen Schulterpolster
einsetzen,
dann wirkt der Frack weniger schwer.
- Ah!
Ja. Ja, das stimmt.
Dann wirken auch
die Arme länger.
Gleichzeitig werden in
Fribourg die beiden Komiker,
die auf der Jubiläumstournee
mit dem Zirkus
durch das Welschland
touren, vorgestellt:
Vincent Kucholl und
Vincent Veillon.
Wir sind sozusagen die welsche
Version von den beiden.
Logisch, diese Ähnlichkeit
- ist doch klar.
Welcher bist du? Der Dicke?
Und ich bin der Alte?
Du bist der Alte, genau.
Sie haben einfach genau
hier reingepasst.
Und sie sind in der
welschen Schweiz gerade in,
sie sind sehr beliebt.
Deshalb sind wir froh,
dass sie kommen.
Ich bin ein absoluter
Kontrollfreak.
Er etwas weniger.
Aber im Zirkus
müssen wir lernen,
live vor und mit dem
Publikum zu spielen.
Auch die Akustik
wird anders sein.
All das wird auch die Art verändern,
wie wir die Sketches schreiben.
Das ist interessant,
etwas Neues.
C'est Vincent Kucholl
et Vincent Veillon.
Yeah, like that.
- Three, two, one.
* Lachen * Hey, Vincent!
Wir schauen auch etwas umher:
Wer hat Erfolg, wer könnte
in den Zirkus passen?
Denn nicht jeder
passt in den Zirkus.
Nicht richtig gepasst hat
der Basler Komiker Almi
im Jahr 2001.
Es ist ja Fredy, der diese - u.a.
auch Komiker ...
Dort machte Fredy
einen Fehlgriff.
Das war ganz klar
eine Fehlbesetzung.
Das spürte Almi selbst
schon bei der Premiere.
Du wusstest: 2'500 Leute
sitzen in diesem Zelt.
Als ich hereingekommen bin, hat
es mir fast den Boden weggezogen.
So viele Leute, die
Anspannung und alles ...
Ich komme herein, und im Moment,
in dem ich hereinkommen,
ging ein Platzregen los.
Es knallte und polterte.
Der Tonmeister musste das
Mikrofon immer lauter einstellen,
es begann zu pfeifen.
Nach meiner Nummer kamen wieder
die Pferde ins Zirkuszelt.
Es hörte auf zu regnen.
Als ob Petrus den Hahn zudreht.
Und jedes Mal, wenn ich hereinkam,
begann es wieder zu regnen.
Als würde oben jemand sagen:
Du gehörst nicht hier rein.
Es friert mich gerade,
wenn ich das so erzähle.
Es war so unglaublich.
Dass er nicht in
die Manege gehöre,
schrieb auch der "Blick"
die ganze Zeit.
Wenn man negative Presse liest,
ist natürlich klar,
dass es einen berührt.
Man denkt einen Moment lang: "Hallo?
Was ist los?"
Es trifft einen, klar.
Man liest nicht, es sei
eine Bombe gewesen,
die Leute tobten,
"Der grösste Star".
Ist ja klar.
Ich habe es von
Anfang an gesehen
und habe es dann auch - nicht
böse, aber schon kritisch ...
Und ich war auch
nicht der Einzige.
Schon nach einer Woche war
Almi nicht mehr erwünscht.
Ich hätte eigentlich erwartet,
dass Familie Knie sagt: "Wir
arbeiten noch mal daran."
(Fredy Knie jun.) Wir haben
uns täuschen lassen.
Wir sagten: "Es ist
besser, wenn du gehst."
"Wenn wir dich mitschleifen,
und es so schlecht ist,
und du dich nicht ändern
willst und kannst ..."
Das wäre schlechte
Werbung für ihn gewesen.
Dann haben wir uns getrennt.
Einer der grössten Komiker überhaupt
ging regelmässig in den Zirkus Knie,
aber als Zuschauer.
Ça va, jeune homme?
- Et toi, ça va?
Oui, ça va.
Charlie Chaplin kannte
natürlich unsere Eltern.
Er war immer im Zirkus.
Ab dem ersten Jahr, in dem er
in der Schweiz gewohnt hatte,
kam er jedes Jahr, am
Wochenende in Vevey.
Wir waren Kinder, spielten
mit seinen Kindern.
Es ging einfach automatisch.
Mein Vater sah immer sich
selbst in den Zirkusartisten.
Ich weiss noch, wie
er immer sagte:
"Das Gute am Zirkus Knie ist,
dass er nicht zu gross ist."
Im Knie hat man den
Kontakt zu den Artisten.
Das gefiel ihm.
Hier draussen waren wir immer.
Wenn das Wetter schön war,
tranken wir den Tee draussen.
Und wir rannten hier im ganzen
Park mit den Tieren herum.
Alles war sehr lustig.
(Eugene Chaplin) Mein Vater lud
gerne Artisten und v.a. Dompteure
zu uns nach Hause ein.
Er sagte, sie könnten
ihre Tiere mitbringen
und Fotos vor dem Haus machen.
So waren Affen, ein Krokodil
und ein Bär bei uns.
Ich kann mich an alles erinnern.
Es ist so, wie es war,
nichts ist verändert.
Das ist das Coole daran.
Alle Kinder waren da, er war
da, machte den Clown für uns.
Wenn ich ins Chaplin-Museum gehe,
macht das schon etwas melancholisch.
* Schwere Klavier-
und Streichmusik *
In Aigle bekommt der Zirkus Knie
Besuch von Geraldine Chaplin
und ihrem Mann.
Trois!
- Und schon ist sie wieder weg.
Seit ich klein bin und bis heute
ist das immer noch der
wichtigste Moment für mich:
wenn der Zirkus Knie kommt.
Fredy und Rolf senior waren
mit meinem Vater befreundet.
Wir Kinder sind da
hereingewachsen.
Wir waren alle in Fredy
junior verliebt.
Als er dann Mary-José
geheiratet hat,
haben wir sie auch ins
Herz geschlossen.
Die Liebesgeschichte
geht also weiter.
Wow, es ist ja richtig
voll hier drin.
* Rasante Orchestermusik *
* Applaus *
Es gibt nur einen Zirkus auf
der Welt, und das ist Knie.
Sie sind die
Königsfamilie, die Royals.
Das höre ich persönlich
nicht so gern.
Aber es ist klar,
dass die Leute einem manchmal
einen solchen Titel anhängen.
Damit kann ich auch leben.
Aber ich fühle mich nicht als
Royal, sondern als normaler Mensch.
Es ist nicht nur die
Liebe zum Zirkus,
die Geraldine Chaplin ganz eng
mit der Familie Knie verbindet.
Bei Knies gab es immer Buben,
also überlegten wir
uns einen Bubennamen.
Aber dann fragte ihr Vater: "Was,
wenn es ein Mädchen wird?"
Wir streichelten zusammen
meinen Bauch, und plötzlich -
das vergesse ich nie wieder
- sagt er: Géraldine.
Ich konnte es nicht glauben.
"Was? Knies? Das ist die
Königsfamilie der Schweiz."
"Sie geben ihrem ersten Mädchen
nach fünf Generationen
den Namen Géraldine?"
Ich machte im Kopf Luftsprünge.
Géraldine ist die
siebte Generation.
Schöne Erinnerungen.
Ich war hochschwanger.
Hat Fredy schon angerufen?
In den letzten 5 Min.?
Nein.
Es kann jeden Moment kommen.
- Er.
Knies haben immer Buben,
seit Generationen.
So, so. Und wenn es
doch ein Mädchen wird?
Tss.
* Das Telefon klingelt. *
Fredy, bist du es?
Da bin ich aber froh.
Was, ein Mädchen?
Und bambina!
Das kann nicht sein. Gib
mir mal diese Hebamme!
Ja, wenn ich es sage!
Sie, welches Geschlecht
hat dieses Kind?
Wie heisst es?
Tatsächlich. - Wie es heisst!
Fredy?
Wie heisst es denn, dieses ...
Mädchen?
Géraldine-Katharina.
Sagen Sie Mary-José alles Liebe!
Ja. Macht's gut!
So.
Jetzt nehmen wir
aber einen Cognac.
(Fredy Knie jun.) Für meine
Grossmutter war es natürlich gut:
Es geht weiter, die
neue Generation.
Dann sagte sie: "Aber versprich mir,
dass du noch einen Buben machst!"
Ich sagte: "Ja, ja!"
Sie dachte halt immer noch
ein wenig geschäftlich.
Dadurch, dass Géraldine
wirklich das erste Mädchen war,
fragte sie sich: "Wie
geht das jetzt weiter?"
Ich habe nie gespürt, dass es,
weil ich ein Mädchen bin,
nicht gehe oder ich nicht
weitermachen könne.
Ich war ein moderner Vater.
Wenn wir spazieren gingen, habe
auch ich den Kinderwagen gestossen.
Dann kam mein Vater: "Aber das
muss dann schon die Frau machen."
So ein wenig altmodisch.
Regeln, die es früher gab und
wegen denen er sich fragte:
Warum geht es nicht so weiter?
Bei Knies spricht man ja immer
von der siebten Generation,
jetzt von der achten Generation.
Dieses Denken gibt es
schon über Jahrhunderte
und es wird immer weitergeführt.
Dieses kleine Mädchen hier
übernimmt heute die Verantwortung
für den grossen Zirkus Knie -
zusammen mit anderen Vertretern
der siebten Generation.
In den Zirkus kommen jedes
Jahr auch viele Prominente.
Knies hatten schon immer ein
sehr gutes Verhältnis zu Stars.
Es war nicht nur
Charlie Chaplin.
Es gibt Fotoalben darüber,
welche Stars und Prominenten
bei ihnen die
Zirkusvorstellungen besuchen.
Ich glaube, das ist ein sehr
gutes Marketinginstrument.
Man hat immer geschaut,
dass man diese Leute auch
in die Manege bringt,
dass man sie ins Publikum bringt,
dass man Kontakt zu ihnen hat.
* Stimmengewirr *
Mit der Familie des Komikers
Dimitri sind Knies eng befreundet.
Auch mit der Tochter Masha.
Wir gehörten schon immer zur Familie.
Auch heute noch.
Wenn ich sie treffe, sind sie
wie eine Familie für mich.
Ich fühle mich hier so
akzeptiert, wie ich bin -
egal ob wir Witze
machen oder ernst sind.
Ich habe das Gefühl, wir sind
auf der gleichen Wellenlänge.
1973 machte ich im Kinderzirkus
mit und war sofort begeistert.
Ich war ein hyperaktives
und schwieriges Mädchen.
Da war der Zirkus
perfekt für mich.
Angefangen hat es
wirklich mit Dimitri.
Er war einer der Ersten, die von
der Bühne zum Zirkus kamen.
Es war ein riesiges Experiment.
Als mein Vater damit
angefangen hat,
meinten alle, jetzt sei
er verrückt geworden.
* Zarte, geheimnisvolle Klänge *
Das erste Mal ging mein Vater 1970
mit dem Zirkus Knie auf Tournee.
Damals ist er mit einem
Elefanten aufgetreten.
(Franco Knie sen.) Das
war ein Riesenerfolg.
Er konnte sehr gut
mit Tieren umgehen.
Er war sehr feinfühlig,
und Elefanten lieben das.
Er war so ein herzlicher Mensch.
Und ein Künstler.
Und sein Lachen. Ich vermisse v.a.
sein Lachen.
Dimitri war ein Mime.
Das war nicht Zirkustradition.
Aber wir haben immer den Zirkus
mit der Moderne vermischt.
Und ich glaube, das ist auch ein
wenig unser Erfolgsgeheimnis.
* Melancholische
Blasmusik, Applaus *
* Stimmengewirr *
Man trifft sich nach der
Vorstellung gern im Medienwagen.
Früher traf man sich sozusagen
bei Margrit zu Hause
in ihrem privaten Wohnwagen - ein
geschichtsträchtiger Wohnwagen.
Wagen 29 wurde ursprünglich
für Favre gebaut,
den Architekten, der den
Gotthardtunnel gemacht hat.
Er hat sich diesen
Wagen bauen lassen
und stellte ihn hier
hoch, auf die Baustelle,
damit er dort wohnen konnte.
Als der Tunnel fertig war, schrieb
er den Wagen zum Verkauf aus.
Mein Grossvater hat ihn gekauft.
Wagen 29 war Margrits Wohnwagen.
Und es war der Empfangswagen, in dem
die ganze Schweiz empfangen wurde.
Es war der Partywagen: Wenn
jemand aus der Familie
Geburtstag hatte oder
ein Fest feierte,
war das immer in
ihrem Wohnwagen.
Für all das wollten ihre Söhne
dann mal einen neuen Wagen.
Rolf, was ist?
Schau!
Das wäre jetzt der
neue Medienwagen.
Ausgerüstet mit allem, was
es heutzutage so braucht.
Sieht gut aus. Und, hast
du ihn schon bestellt?
Noch nicht. - Warum nicht?
Können wir uns das nicht leisten?
- Doch, doch, das schon.
Aber Mutter ... Ich weiss
nicht, wie sie das aufnimmt.
Sie hat die Medienleute genug lang
in ihrem eigenen Wagen bewirtet,
bis tief in die Nacht. Sie
kann einfach nicht mehr.
Das sagst du.
Aber sie macht keine
Anstalten, damit aufzuhören.
* Ächzen, Löwenknurren *
Dann müssen wir mit ihr reden.
Komm! Wir beide.
* Schräge Blasmusik *
Meinst du wirklich, jetzt
sei der richtige Moment?
Nein, der richtige
Moment kommt nie.
Mutter?
Rolf und ich möchten
dich etwas fragen.
Wir finden beide ... es
wäre an der Zeit ...
... dass wir ... einen
neuen Medienwagen kaufen.
Rolf hat schon ...
- Das hier ist der Medienwagen.
Er war es immer und
bleibt es auch.
Aber Mutter ... - Nichts da!
Und wenn es euch nicht passt ...
(Beide) ... können wir
einen Stocken dazustecken.
(Fredy Knie jun.) Mein
Vater und mein Onkel
hatten diesen Pressewagen
bestellt, um sie zu entlasten.
Das war für sie vielleicht wie:
"Sie brauchen mich nicht mehr."
Solange Margrit lebte, wurde der
neue Wagen nicht geliefert.
In Lugano gastiert der Zirkus Knie
jedes Jahr am Schluss seiner Tournee.
* Geheimnisvolle Klänge *
Es ist ein sehr
trauriger Tag für mich.
(Franco Knie sen.) Es ist immer
eine ganz komische Stimmung
an der letzten Vorstellung. So
empfand ich es früher immer.
Denn man ist traurig,
aber z.B. die Artisten sind im Kopf
schon beim nächsten Engagement.
Man organisiert schon weiter
und hat fast keine Zeit, sich
richtig zu verabschieden.
Man realisiert erst nachher,
dass die nicht mehr da sind.
Es ist eine ganz
komische Stimmung.
* Entfernte Musik
übertönt das Gespräch. *
* Triumphale Klänge *
* Jubel *
* Schreie *
* Applaus, die Musik verklingt. *
* Melancholische Musik,
rhythmisches Klatschen *
Nach der letzten Vorstellung
kehren die Pferde sofort
zurück in die Deutschschweiz.
Ich schaue mal, ob die
Transportwagen hier sind,
damit man sie danach gleich einladen kann.
Noch nix da?
Er sagte, er sei um
19 Uhr hier, aber ...
Ich weiss nicht, wohin die fahren.
Oder sind sie schon dort?
Es macht mich traurig, dass ich
meine Freunde verlassen muss.
Und erst noch nach einer
so schönen Saison.
Nach achteinhalb Monaten
mit so wunderbaren Leuten.
Es ist jedes Jahr traurig,
ich mag es nicht.
Auch wegen meiner Nummer. Wegen allem!
Ich mag es nicht.
Wenn ich dann eine Woche zu
Hause bin, geht es besser.
Also Jungs, das letzte Mal!
Nachher gehen wir
alle in die Ferien.
Avatar!
Gehen sie die Wagen jetzt holen?
Hallo?
Holt ihr die ...
Holt ihr die Wagen hierher?
Ja. - Die Pferdewagen
hierherbringen.
Ah, ja, ich kann ...
- Wo ist der andere?
Sie sind vorne.
- Welcher Wagen zuerst?
14, 114.
14, 114 zuerst.
Ja, okay, gleich hier. Okay, gut.
Danke, ciao.
Ja, ist egal. Ist
egal, kein Problem.
Nachher Jade.
Nachher Malac.
Shalimar.
* Virtuose E-Gitarrenmusik *
Two champagnes. - Thank you.
* Stimmengewirr *
Klar freue ich mich auf die
neue Saison, das ist ganz klar.
Aber ich bin überhaupt
nicht saisonmüde.
Von mir aus könnte
es noch weitergehen.
Aber es stimmt mich immer
etwas melancholisch.
Ich mag den Schluss nicht.
Ich weiss: Jetzt geht
etwas auseinander,
das nie wieder so zusammenkommt.
Einen Teil sehe ich
nächstes Jahr wieder,
aber einen Teil sehe ich
vielleicht nie wieder.
Er hört nach 40 Jahren
Zirkus heute auf:
Lahoucine Amayous.
(Alle) Amayous! Amayous!
Wir haben in Bern eine
grosse Jubiläumsparty.
Und für die Jubiläumsparty
laden wir Amayous ein.
Wir holen dich mit dem Flugzeug.
Und er bleibt in Bern bei uns.
Und vor dem Abbautag
muss er wieder gehen,
denn sonst muss er
den Abbau machen.
* Lachen, Applaus *
* Schwermütige Streichmusik *
Vom Tessin kehrt der Zirkus zurück
ins Hauptquartier nach Rapperswil -
um zu überwintern.
Wir sind im Winter nicht im
Winterschlaf, wie viele vermuten.
Wir bereiten schon wieder
die nächste Saison vor.
Der Winter ist also sehr
kurz und auch sehr intensiv.
* Verspielte,
glockenartige Klänge *
(Géraldine Knie) Wir
sind oft im Wohnwagen,
weil sie neben der
Reithalle stehen.
Wir sind in erster Linie
in der Nähe der Pferde.
Alles läuft hier ab.
Lecker, gell?
Burak!
(Géraldine Knie) Wir sind
jetzt voll in der Probephase
für das neue Programm.
Was genau klappen wird und was
nicht, steht noch in den Sternen.
* Knallen *
Chanel ist sehr
ehrgeizig, fast zu stark.
Aber sie ist halt
so, eine Wilde.
Jetzt.
Changer!
Die Systeme, wie man
mit Tieren umgeht,
ändern sich von
Generation zu Generation.
Ich habe mein
eigenes entwickelt.
Und ich bin sicher: Géraldine wird
sich auch noch mal entwickeln.
Und Ivan und Chanel auch.
Am Anfang ist es immer so,
dass die einen Mist machen.
Das muss man korrigieren.
Hier, allez! Hoch, hoch!
Hoch!
- Noch mal mit der Peitsche, ja!
Hoch, hoch, hoch!
- Komm, lauf schneller, schneller!
Schneller, schneller!
Gut, fertig, ab!
Einen Monat vor der Premiere
reisen die Artisten an.
Hallo! Wie geht's? Gut?
Auch Dima Sokolov mit
seiner Truppe aus Russland.
* Anschwellende
geheimnisvolle Musik *
In Rapperswil bauen
Maycol und seine Leute
zum ersten Mal das
neue Zelt auf.
Okay, fix. Puoi vederlo
dall'altra parte?
* Unverständlicher Ruf *
Kontrolliere die Platte!
* Metallisches Rattern *
Das Crowdfunding
hat funktioniert:
Das neue Zelt ist ein
Geschenk des Publikums.
Es ist immer der schönste Moment,
wenn das Zelt wieder steht,
wenn alle Mitarbeiter wieder da sind.
Ja: Herzklopfen.
Weisst du, wo das Material ist?
Wo sind die Sitzreihen?
Nichts ist hier.
Das Material für die
Sitzreihen ist nicht da.
Die zwei Paletten.
Normalerweise in der 13.
- Camille hat sie eingepackt.
Aber wo?
Camille anrufen. - Ja.
Aber ich will keine Verzögerung.
Heute ist Montage und fertig.
Alex sagte, es fehlen Masten.
Ohne Mastenbogen wird es morgen.
Jetzt.
- Ich weiss nicht, was ...
Ich sage dir offiziell: jetzt.
- Ja, ja.
Jetzt braucht es
natürlich viel Teamwork,
und v.a. sind es
neue Situationen.
Dadurch, dass der zweite
Bogenmast auch draussen ist,
muss man neu verkabeln
und zuschneiden.
Sie wollten es morgen
machen, aber ich sagte:
"Nein, wir machen heute so
viel wie möglich fertig."
Und das Wetter
spielt ja auch mit.
Bis jetzt passt alles,
es funktioniert.
Ich hoffe, es geht so weiter.
Doch, ich bin
wirklich zufrieden.
Bravo!
* Alle reden durcheinander. "
* Treibende Klavier-
und Streichmusik *
Das Zelt steht, die
Technik ist bereit
und die Proben in der
Manege können losgehen.
Diese Halterungen für
das Licht aufs Zelt -
ich will jetzt, dass
das vorwärtsgeht.
Man weiss, dass man Anfang Saison
auch am Wochenende arbeiten muss.
Das kann man später
wieder abbauen.
* Vereinzelte Basstöne *
Es ändert sich in den letzten
zweieinhalb Wochen noch ganz viel,
das ist klar.
Feinstarbeit.
Licht, Musik, Choreografie, das
muss alles zusammenspielen.
Deshalb wird das jetzt auch
alles per Computer koordiniert.
Auch Viktor Giacobbo und
Mike Müller proben -
die Zugpferde der
Jubiläumstournee.
Gell, wenn die Longe weg ist ...
Wenn ich ihn mal gestartet habe,
kann ich ihn nicht mehr bremsen.
Aus Paris ist Bruno Fatalot
angereist, der Schneider,
für die letzten Korrekturen
an den Kostümen.
Er kommt immer eine knappe
Woche vor der Saisonpremiere.
Dann ist die letzte Anprobe.
Jetzt geht es ums Feintuning.
Wenn es hier und dort noch zieht
und zupft, passt man es an.
Und in diesem Jahr ist speziell,
dass wir mit der Papageiennummer
versteckte Taschen
brauchen für die Nüsse,
damit sie eine Belohnung
haben während des Auftritts.
Vielleicht kannst du es
noch ein wenig verstärken.
Ich mache es nachher
noch besser.
Man ist nie wirklich bereit,
bis zum Schluss nicht.
Das ist normal.
* Popballade von Jennifer
Lopez: "Feel the Light" *
Nach einer längeren Pause
tritt auch Géraldine,
die künstlerische Direktorin,
wieder selber in der Manege auf.
Zur Freude ihres Vaters.
Géraldine ist wieder topfit.
Sie hat drei Kinder bekommen
und hatte auch schwere Zeiten.
Es war für sie sicher ein
Problem und ein lager Weg.
Aber diese Entscheidung,
stark abzunehmen -
es waren doch 25 kg - muss von
der Person selbst kommen.
Ich wollte nicht mehr
reiten mit dem Übergewicht.
Denn es ist nicht ... Es
geht für mich einfach nicht.
Es hat mir schon sehr
gefehlt all die Jahre.
Ich habe mir einfach
vorgenommen:
"Ich möchte abnehmen. Dann
gehe ich wieder aufs Pferd."
Non dobbiamo vedere Viktor.
Viktor arriva lì, blackout.
Ruslan, eine ganze Minute, und
du schaust einfach nicht!
Es läuft nichts wie geschmiert,
und das ist auch richtig so.
Dass man nervös ist, ist auch richtig.
Man muss nervös sein.
Nimmt man alles gleichgültig
hin, ist man nicht mehr gut.
Perché sei: bam.
No! Deve essere: bam!
Bam! Bam! Blackout!
Ich bin hier, Maycol dort, dann
auf drei: bam, bam, blackout,
zusammen mit der Musik.
Ich verstehe es
einfach nicht, sorry.
C'est: bam!
Er ist nervös.
Etwas wie: boom! Weisst du?
- Bam!
Nein, ohne "piep". Einfach ein
"boom", dann "tan, tan, tan!"
Forte, fortissimo: boom!
Mais pas les trompettes
"piep", tu sais?
Let's try it with no brass.
Das ist normal.
Und ich bin auch einer,
der schnell nervös wird.
Natürlich sind wir in diesem Jahr
noch nervöser und gestresster.
Es sind immerhin 100 Jahre Zirkus.
Es ist immer das Gleiche:
Die Zeit ist knapp, und
es gibt viele Probleme.
Und wir wollen etwas
Spezielles machen.
* Energiegeladene
Schlagzeugrhythmen *
* Applaus *
Das war mein Fehler.
Es ist perfekt.
Je mehr wir sind, umso mehr
verschiedene Meinungen gibt es.
Aber das Schlusswort habe
eigentlich schon ich.
Sie "müssen" oder dürfen
machen, was ich ...
Sie müssen natürlich
meine Wünsche erfüllen.
Aber das funktioniert auch gut.
Der letzte Abend
vor der Premiere.
Morgen feiert Familie Knie das
100-jährige Bestehen ihres Zirkus.
In 100 Jahren gab es auch
sehr schwierige Zeiten.
Es gab glorreiche Zeiten. Es
war immer ein Auf und Ab.
So auch im Leben von
Margrit Lippuner,
die als junge Frau zur
Familie Knie kam,
im Zirkus mit ihrem Mann Friedrich
die beiden Söhne grosszog,
und auf jeder Tournee
mit dabei war -
bis ins hohe Alter.
Nonna wurde älter.
Sie hat dann weniger gemacht,
war aber immer präsent.
Denn sie war eine
sehr starke Frau.
Sie war bis am Schluss
voll da, bis 77.
* Sanfte Streichmusik *
Nonna, bist du sicher,
dass du in diesem Zustand
allein schlafen willst?
Was denn? Mir geht es bestens.
Ich kann bei dir übernachten.
Oder Mary-José.
Ich komme schon zurecht.
Mach dir keine Umstände!
Mir ist nicht wohl,
wenn du allein bist.
Weisst du, wie viele Jahre
ich schon allein bin?
Wenn etwas ist, kann ich ja rufen.
- Versprochen?
Versprochen. So, gute Nacht, Fredy.
- Gute Nacht, Nonna.
Hilfe annehmen - das
konnte Margrit nicht gut,
auch wenn sie darauf
angewiesen war.
Wir versuchten sie alle zu
trösten und wollten ihr sagen:
"Es ist jetzt halt so." Und
sie hat es auch begriffen.
Es war nicht so, dass sie
es nicht begriffen hat.
Aber im Innersten tat es ihr weh.
Das ist klar.
* Melancholische Streichmusik *
Dann kam diese sehr
schwere Grippe.
Diese traf sie schwer und davon
erholte sie sich nicht mehr.
* Husten *
Einen Tag, bevor sie
starb, ging ich noch ...
Wir waren in Winterthur, sie war in St.
Gallen im Spital.
Ich ging allein zu ihr, ich
wollte niemanden dabei haben.
Und ...
Ich war bei ihr im Zimmer, und sie
war irgendwie nicht mehr ganz da.
Wie von ganz weit weg sagte sie ein
paar Worte und sprach mit mir.
Sie hat mich schon angesprochen.
Und das hat mich sehr berührt.
Dann ging ich nach Hause - also
nach Winterthur -, um zu arbeiten.
Das war ja im Sinn all
unserer Vorfahren:
Es muss weitergehen,
es muss weitergehen.
* Entfernte Rufe,
Trommelwirbel, Lachen *
* Schwere Streichmusik *
* Applaus, Blasmusik *
Ich glaube, Emotionen sind,
dass man sie zeigen kann.
Und man soll sie auch zeigen.
Aber in der Vorstellung
sicher nicht.
Man geht durch den Vorgang
und ist da fürs Publikum.
(Flüsternd) Allez!
* Fröhliche Orchestermusik *
Das Verarbeiten bei uns ist
weiterarbeiten, weiterarbeiten.
Das hilft ein wenig.
Aber die Realität ist
da, dass es so ist.
* Anschwellende,
hohe Zupfklänge *
Und jetzt ist er da,
der Abend, auf den Familie Knie
so lange hingearbeitet hat:
die Premiere der
Jubiläumstournee.
Man überlegt sich: "Wird
die Nummer gefallen?"
Jetzt, wo Premiere ist, sowieso.
Man macht sich schon
Gedanken darüber.
* Spannungsgeladene
Streichmusik *
Dieses Jahr ist
natürlich speziell.
Ich bin ziemlich
nervös, angespannt.
Das ist normal - es
ist eine Liveshow.
Ich bin natürlich sehr stolz,
zu sehen, wie es weitergeht,
mit den Kindern und Enkeln.
Und dass sie schon so
gute Artisten sind.
Auch die Kleinsten haben
es schon im Blut.
Das freut mich wirklich.
Es geht allen anders:
Die einen werden
fast hysterisch,
fressen Nägel, andere
haben Schweissausbrüche.
Oder die einen sagen vor
Schreck gar nichts.
Jeder reagiert anders,
das ist klar.
* Stimmengewirr im Hintergrund *
* Energiegeladene,
fanfarenartige Musik *
* Spannungsgeladene
Orchestermusik *
* Jubel *
* Applaus,
spannungsgeladene Musik *
Als Géraldine klein war,
hatte ich mit ihr eine Nummer
wie damals die "Muppet Show".
Alle Figuren der "Muppet
Show" sassen auf den Ponys.
Das war wirklich ein
grosser Lacher.
* Lachen, heitere Musik *
Wir sagten: "Machen wir das
doch wieder mit Chanel!"
Sie schaute mich so an.
"Nonno, was ist das?"
Ich sagte: "Das ist deine
Nummer." "Aber wieso?"
"Du wirst sehen, wie
die Leute lachen."
* Lachen, melancholische
Popmusik *
Wegen der Nervosität stehe ich
nicht gern drin und schaue zu.
Das macht mich nervös. Deswegen
höre ich von draussen zu.
* Spannungsgeladene
Musik, Pfeifen *
* Applaus *
* Tangoartige Musik,
rhythmisches Klatschen *
* Musik und Applaus verklingen. *
* Popballade von Jennifer
Lopez: "Feel the Light" *
# Feel the light shining
like the stars tonight.
# Remember what we forgot,
I know it's a long shot.
# But we're bringing it all
back, bringing it all back.
Ich bin mega happy, erleichtert
und nur glücklich.
* Triumphale Orchestermusik *
Mein traditioneller
Traum vor der Premiere
ist immer der gleiche Traum:
dass ich versuche, die Stiefel
anzuziehen, diese aber zu eng sind
und ich nicht reinkomme. Dann
wache ich auf, schweissgebadet.
Den habe ich jedes Jahr, ich
weiss auch nicht, wieso.
* Epische Orchestermusik,
Applaus *
* Bewundernde Rufe *
(Ivan Knie) Grossvater stand
sein Leben lang in der Manege.
Die Pferde kann man
ihm nie wegnehmen.
Er wird auf jeden Fall
immer dabei sein.
* Fröhliche Popmusik,
rhythmisches Klatschen *
Jetzt ist es für mich Zeit,
die Verantwortung des Zirkus
an die siebte und achte
Generation zu übergeben.
Es gibt nichts Schöneres für
mich, als ihnen dabei zuzusehen,
wie auch ihre Wünsche
in Erfüllung gehen.
Vielen Dank und auf Wiedersehen!
* Applaus, fröhliche Popmusik *
Für mich ist es einfach
auch ein runder Abschluss.
Ich habe 73 Jahre lang
in diesem Zirkus gelebt
und gesehen, wie sich ganze
Generationen entwickelt haben.
Jetzt die siebte und
die achte Generation.
Das ist für mich mit sehr
vielen Emotionen verbunden.
* Applaus, zarte Blasmusik *
Fredy junior tritt ab.
Und wieder einmal geht eine Ära in
der Familiengeschichte zu Ende.
Aber die Geschichte der
Dynastie Knie geht weiter.